[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle écologie agriculture
alimentation mais aussi politique et
cette semaine nous recevons Agnès Firmin
le Baudot bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Agnès pierre
malobodo vous êtes ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé auprès du
ministre François Braun logique pour la
pharmacienne de profession que vous êtes
et qui exerce toujours vous avez
largement repris du service pendant le
covid vous vous êtes engagé en politique
dès 1983 au côté d'Antoine ruffenacle
l'ancien maire RPR du Havre vous êtes
son adjointe avant de devenir celle
d'Edouard Philippe en 2017 vous êtes élu
sous l'étiquette les républicains puis
vous confondez agir devenu horizon dont
vous êtes la porte-parole fidèle à votre
mentor Édouard Philippe comme à la ville
du Havre vous chérissez la mer un indice
pour le menu du jour Jean-Pierre
exactement avec des crevettes grillées
des gambas même accompagnées de patates
douces au miel et on desserre un dessert
régressif un riz au lait dans le dessous
des plats la folie des bonbons avec des
nouvelles tendances des bonbons vintage
sans sucre ou encore alcoolisme dans les
pieds dans plat après les bonbons plats
au régime avant l'été en quête sur les
coupes fin vendus en pharmacie à vous
couper l'appétit
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidente
alors Agnès Firma le Bodo je tenais à
vous dire bravo car vous avez exigé un
plat à la fois gourmand et singulier
c'est la première fois que nous avons le
plaisir de déguster avec Brigitte des
crevettes voir des gambas à ses tables
et en même temps vous ne trahissez pas
votre statue de ministre délégué à la
santé et de pharmacienne à la fois oui
c'est davantage qu'un menu j'allais dire
c'est une prescription presque rédigée
par une blouse blanche et oui la
crevette Brigitte et l'aliment santé par
excellence bourré d'antioxydants bon
pour la lutte contre le cancer bourré de
fer de vitamines B3 qui brûlent des
graisses se crustacés est aussi source
de protéines parfait pour la masse
musculaire plein diodes de phosphore de
magnésium de zinc et de cuivre et cerise
sur le gâteau la crevette est très peu
calorique moins que la dinde c'est dire
alors vous auriez pu être transgressive
avec un beignet ou un tempura de
crevettes mais non la voilà nue sans
matière grasse juste grillée alors j'ai
une petite question je me dis que vous
devriez militer pour que cette crevette
soit remboursée par la Sécurité Sociale
je ne sais pas si d'homilité pour le
remboursement la crevette en tout cas en
tout cas la maritime que je suis je suis
néo a comme vous l'avez rappelé j'y
habite toujours et pour moi les produits
de la mer sont
les meilleurs produits c'est ce que je
préfère j'aurais pu aussi choisir les
huîtres mais numéro 1 c'est la crevette
pour les j'aime beaucoup les crevettes
et surtout ces formes ça peut être un
beignet de crevettes aussi mais je
trouve que les crevettes grillées ça
suffit à soi-même vraiment mais c'est
une question de goût c'est pas tellement
mon argument là parce que c'est un
argument santé finalement ça vous
dépasse ça j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses et c'est pas du tout
c'est vraiment une question une question
de goût et
aussi par excellence quand même c'est il
se trouve par bonheur que c'est un
aliment sain et comme vous le savez je
ne mange que des aliments sains on en
discutera peut-être tout à l'heure mais
voilà c'est vraiment la crevette et
celle-ci elle est grillée mais j'aime
bien aussi des toutes petites crevettes
grises à éplucher à l'apéro c'est très
sympa vous les mangez pas directement
comme ça vous les épluchez les tout
petit
dans le Nord là bon on peut manger les
petites
alors là ce sont des gambas parce
qu'elles sont grandes crevettes le nom
le gambas c'est un nom espagnol c'est
plutôt des crevettes de Méditerranée
mais elles sont belles c'est pas celle
qu'on trouve finalement dans la baie
le petit bouquet notamment aussi dans la
Manche les péchés le petit bouquet ce
que je faisais quand j'étais plus jeune
et que j'avais un peu de temps
le bouquet de coscoville
finalement c'est bien sûr c'est voilà
aussi la mer est toujours très proche de
moi et donc les produits de la mer sont
d'abord des bons produits pour la santé
vous avez eu raison de le rappeler mais
c'est aussi des très bons produits au
goûtez
et vous allez nous dire si elles sont
aussi bonnes que celles que vous pouvez
elles ont l'air bonne elles ont elles
sont bien présentées dans l'assiette ça
c'est déjà important aussi vrai il y a
des herbes aussi dessus il y a des
herbes il y a des petites herbes elles
sont juste grillées et elles sont très
peu cuites elles sont dures elles sont
elles sont très coûteuses parce que
souvent trop cuites voilà
chez Françoise vous vous avez l'habitude
de les de les cuisiner vous aimez aussi
être derrière les fourneaux
alors j'aime être derrière le fourneau
je dois vous avouer ça fait un certain
temps que je n'ai pas eu le temps d'être
derrière les fourneaux mais j'aime bien
ça et
on a aussi des
ustensiles qui nous permettent de
cuisiner maintenant les crevettes on met
tout dans le hop avec une poêle
c'est très bien un curry de crevette
c'est très bon comme vous la cuisine
d'accord c'est bien trois choses à
savoir Jean-Pierre c'est la crevette sur
les crevettes oui alors il y a plus de
1000 espèces de crevettes qui sont
recensés mais trois seulement se
retrouvent en cuisine les crevettes
nordiques les crevettes nordiques
sauvages les crevettes blanches et les
crevettes tigrées d'élevage on distingue
plusieurs tailles plus le chiffre est
petit et plus la crevette est grosse et
des présentations un peu diverses et
quand on les achète et soit décortiquer
soit sans que soit congelés surgelés il
est très rare de se procurer peut-être
vous au Havre des crevettes n'ayant
jamais été congelés car elles périssent
très vite elles sont toujours congelées
sur le bateau qu'elles soient crues ou
cuite donc même les crevettes en
apparence fraîche que vous voyez sur
métal du poissonnier sont souvent vendus
surgelés puis décongeler pour les
décongeler une astuce les mettre dans un
bol d'eau froide et au bout de quelques
heures elle veut elles vont se
décongeler enfin bien retenir que la
chaleur et l'ennemi des crevettes trop
cuites elles deviennent cotonneuses
voire caoutchouteuse donc par exemple ne
jamais faire cuire des crevettes bouquet
déjà cuites les mettre au dernier moment
pour des brochettes prenez des grosses
crevettes et garder les carapaces qui
vont les protéger de la chaleur et pour
les plans en sauce comme les curry
préférez les crevettes décortiquées
crues que vous ajouterez au dernier
moment pour deux à trois minutes de
cuisson bon alors là on sait tous sur la
sur la crevette l'intéressait d'aller
les pêcher comme ça elles sont pas
congelés vous aimez vous justement aller
à la pêche j'aimais bien quand j'étais
jeune maintenant j'ai vraiment besoin
d'aller pêcher avec le avec le fil avec
l'avion
faut profiter des fortes forts
coefficients de marée pour pouvoir le
faire et là ils sont pas congelés mais
au Havre quand vous allez directement
chez le chez le pêcheur sur le sur
lequel les crevettes et les bouquets
directement pêchés sont pas congelés ils
ont pas le temps mais elles sortent du
elle sort du bateau
au bord de mer parce que souvent les
crevettes bouquets chez les poissonniers
elles sont déjà cuites souvent ne sont
pas qui toi sont pas tes congelés elles
sont cuites
que ça de bien cuire les crevettes non
je l'ai dit il faut vraiment que ça
cuise et là c'est effectivement juste
cuite en fait presque saisissent enfin
il faut les saisir et puis les manger à
presque cru à coeur en fait c'est
presque meilleur c'est ça et vous aimez
du coup vous tout les poissons crus
aussi les sushis il y a toute cette mode
qui nous vient de du Japon par exemple
c'est quelque chose que vous appréciez
aussi moi j'aime toute forme de poisson
toute forme de crustacés qu'ils soient
cru qu'il soit cuit je pense que c'est
d'abord c'est bon pour la santé le
poisson cru c'est aussi bon pour la
liberté alors pas toujours mais quand
même faut faire aussi qu'il soit frais
pourquoi pas toujours parce qu'il peut y
avoir
en fait le poisson il y a aussi du
mercure il y a aussi des métaux lourds
que ce soit du bon poisson bien pêché
dans des endroits dans des dans des mers
avec juste un petit filet de citron
d'huile d'olive mon petit filet de sol
juste bien voilà les coquilles
Saint-Jacques
du Havre la coquille Saint-Jacques en
pleine saison les coquilles
Saint-Jacques c'est toujours on peut les
manger cru en carpaccio on peut les
faire cuire aussi ça c'est bien je vous
posez une petite question qui va
peut-être vous déranger c'est vrai que
j'adore le Havre c'est une très belle
ville d'un point de vue l'architecture
mais quand on est face à la mer on voit
un peu des industries etc et on se dit
mais est-ce que la mer n'est pas polluée
ce que les poissons sont quand même
comestibles contenu de l'environnement
un peu industriel de la ville et du port
est-ce que c'est une bonne question
c'est difficile d'obtenir le Pavillon
Bleu et donc la plage du Havre
la mer est très simple nous avons une
grande plage de sable et que l'eau n'est
pas bleue comme
non non de toute façon non non quelle
sorte de viande
donner des consignes par exemple à votre
ministère quand vous êtes arrivés vous
leur avez dit ce que ce que j'aimais
beaucoup donc j'ai dit l'oreille
ce sera notre dessert j'ai dit le relais
ce que je n'aimais pas il y a pas grand
chose que je n'aime pas vraiment mais
quand même
peut-être les pois chiches c'est bon
pourtant pour la santé mais visiblement
le rapport santé alimente ça vous ça
vous préoccupe pas alors si si tout a
votre modération tout de façon
équilibrée faut éviter le sel voilà
d'ailleurs je mange régulièrement son
sel et plutôt sans sauce d'ailleurs
accessoirement donc quand même je fais
attention
comme pour tout dans la vie tout est une
question d'équilibre et de proportion
donc voilà donc moi j'ai quasiment de
tout en petite quantité petite avec
le beurre parce que c'est pas terrible
non plus le beurre
j'en mange assez rarement en fait même
pas au petit déjeuner
on n'avait pas eu un député normand qui
Brigitte qui mangeait une tablette par
Breton
c'est pas très mauvais pour la santé je
le redis pour la santé tout est une
question proportion exactement tout est
une question proportion on peut manger
de tout on peut manger de tout sauf
quand on est des problèmes d'allergie
mais tout est une question
proportionnelle mauvais gras mais alors
là le beurre on est plutôt côté mauvais
gras j'imagine
avec un petit peu de Ben coup dessus ou
4 heures c'est très très bon et pour
revenir sur la question de Brigitte sur
la flexitarien ou pas ou flexitarienne
ou pas vous êtes perturbé par tous les
discours il faut manger moins de viande
les Français c'est statistiques mangent
moins de viande est-ce que vous avez
baissé votre conception est-ce que vous
culpabilisez quand vous avez un steak
dans votre assiette non
la réponse je ne peux pas du tout mais
vous n'avez pas du tout changé votre
façon de manger pas du tout non pas du
tout autant que
quand j'ai envie de manger la viande de
poisson je mange de la viande ou du
poisson même pour des raisons
écologiques vous dites pas il faut que
je modère un petit peu ma consommation
je dois avouer que non je je vois bien
la tendance la tendance qui est dans
l'air de se dire il faut manger beaucoup
moins de viande parce que
potentiellement je le redis je ne mange
pas non plus que de la viande donc pour
moi c'est pas un sujet je le redis tout
est une question d'équilibre et
proportion
je suis radicalement modéré et donc
comme je suis radio-cambant modéré dans
les prises de position je suis aussi
radicalement modérée
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas très drôle
mais voilà c'est comme ça
c'est naturel c'est naturel
j'aime bien et je l'assume de dire que
une bonne j'allais dire une bonne
entrecôte grillée c'est bon mais il faut
pas en manger faut pas en manger tous
les jours parce qu'on sait qu'en plus
outre le fait que ça soit sans doute pas
bon pour la planète ça n'est pas bon
pour la santé non plus voilà parce qu'on
a sur les viandes rouges sur les réseaux
il se trouve que par exemple dans mon
cabinet j'ai
des jeunes qui sont plutôt végétariens
ça se respecte aussi c'est un choix dans
votre ministère il y a une journée par
exemple
je mange pas tous les jours à la cantine
mais j'imagine mais il y a des il y a
des personnes qui autour de moi moi je
végétarien tous les jours c'est leur
choix et moi je le respecte et ça nous
amène parfois des discussions assez
rigolotes mais on voulait pas qu'on vous
impose ne pas manger de viande quoi
c'est à dire que vous je pense que ce
serait d'ailleurs aussi pour la santé je
pense que c'est peut-être pas si bon que
ça et peut-être on aura du retour des
années de se dire que l'avion elle
apporte aussi pour la santé quelque
chose je le redis tout est une question
de proportion est-ce que vous l'imaginez
ce jour demain ou après-demain sans
viande et sans poisson sur terre
est-ce que il est inéluctable ou est-ce
que c'est
une table je crois qu'il faut aussi on
parler tout à l'heure on voit bien dans
les cantines la nécessité d'apprendre
aux enfants aussi à manger des légumes
et ce repas végétarien c'est aussi une
façon d'apprendre c'est pas imposer dans
les continents on peut aussi réfléchir
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait du poisson
tout le temps non plus ou assez souvent
dans les cantines parce que d'abord
c'est un coup mais c'est aussi important
d'apprendre aux enfants à manger des
poissons ou des produits qui viennent
qui viennent de la mer ça permet aussi
de faire un petit peu de pédagogie sur
ce qu'est la mer et ceux qui vivent dans
la mer mais manger aussi un peu de
viande de façon je le redis
proportionnée et puis ça permet aussi
d'apprendre beaucoup de choses il y a la
viande rouge il y a la viande blanche la
différence entre la volaille et tout ça
est important et je le redis tout est
une question à la fois de pédagogie et
de proportions donc je ne sais pas moi
je je me projette pas dans dans
100 ans je ne sais pas ce que sera la
terre dans son temps en tout cas ce dont
nous avons la responsabilité de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse vivre bien sur la
planète avec tout ce dont nous avons
besoin pour nous nourrir et pour ça on a
besoin de tout le monde alors pour
accompagner ces crevettes vous nous avez
demandé un petit verre de vin blanc vous
le voyez de cette de la vallée du Rhône
c'est un Condrieu
un appellation donc un Condrieu c'était
une AOC le cépage c'est 100% vionnier
c'est le l'unique cépage d'ailleurs et
c'est un millésime 2021 pourquoi ce
choix bah pourquoi pas
alors il y a un petit peu de vin au
Havre mais très peu c'est quand même pas
la spécialité
qui a produit d'avoir un vent qui
ressemblait beaucoup à celui-ci
vont monter vous allez bientôt avoir des
vignes un tout petit peu d'abord parce
qu'avec les crevettes le vin blanc va
plutôt va plutôt bien et que je suis
plutôt dans ma période vallée du Rhône
donc c'est à dire Condrieu pour le blanc
et plutôt un petit peu côte rôti pour le
rouge d'accord
géographiquement je trouve et à côté je
trouve que le Condrieu un goût très
particulier et on le reconnaît assez
facilement mais on aurait pu choisir en
entredomer ou autre chose mais c'est
vrai que je trouve que le Condrieu est
un très bon vin blanc et un goût qu'on
reconnaît assez facilement et moi le
Lyonnais je valide
merci en tous les cas alors on va voir
si vous êtes vraiment incollables c'est
le quiz
alors vous êtes fan de bonbons on va en
reparler et on vous fera même goûter des
bonbons chaque région de France à ses
propres confiserie ou friandises
seriez-vous nous dire lequel de ces
bonbons n'existe pas alors la Niniche
est-ce que ça existe je crois que oui
c'est une spécialité de Quiberon le
masque noir est-ce que ça existe
j'hésite entre le B et le D je crois que
je crois que le B n'existe pas le masque
le B le masque noir si c'est un bonbon à
la réglisse du Languedoc le téton
de la reine Marie Danjou est-ce que ça
existe est-ce que les anges 20 nous ont
fait ça entre le téton et en dessous je
lis bien ce que je
lises entre le téton et la coucougnette
je ne sais pas je dirais que le téton ça
doit pouvoir exister
celui le téton de la Reine Margot
c'était un praliné aromatisé au Grand
Marnier est recouvert de chocolat blanc
et c'était un hommage à cette reine
reconnu pour ses décolletés provocants
et enfin la téton existe bien la forme
existe bien
et la coucougnette du Vert-Galant
ça existe oui c'est une amende grillée
au chocolat
ce sont des endroits où je n'ai pas
encore fait de déplacement donc
j'invite j’enchains des placements et
sûrement à regarder
pour répondre un petit peu sur ce sujet
là j'ai je suis ministre l'organisation
territorial donc je me déplace beaucoup
et à chaque fois qu'on fait un
déplacement on essaie de ramener une
spécialité de l'endroit où nous allons
pas toujours des bonbons pas toujours
des bonbons il se trouve qu'à Chablis
c'est assez facile
et que vous partagez avec le cabinet
quand on va à Morteau c'est assez facile
de la spécialité de Morteau non non mais
voilà
Quiberon la prochaine fois
et on a ramené du whisky
Belle-Île-en-Mer rien de distillerie qui
fait un whisky est plus original voilà
vous aimez whisky aussi vous êtes à
Madame acheter j'aime pas j'aime pas
j'aime pas whisky c'est trop fort mais
j'aime beaucoup le whisky c'est
intéressant niveau odorant c'est ça le
fait
numéro 2 alors sans dévoiler votre âge
on peut dire que vous êtes né lors d'une
année révolutionnaire
pourriez-vous nous dire quels sont les
dates de ces inventions qui ont
révolutionné la cuisine
à la cuisson sous vide alors est-ce que
c'est en 1929 1863 dans les années 70 ou
en 1953
c'est pas simple comme à faire votre
travail
la cuisson sous vide peut-être entre ces
je dirais c'est le truc le plus récent
peut-être je dirais plutôt les années 70
et ben c'est vrai
mais l'épluche légumes alors est-ce que
c'est 1929 1863 ou 19503 forcément
quelqu'un qui a gagné le concours Lépine
avec les plus légumes certainement
forcément donc on est au XXe siècle
c'est entre 1953 et 1929
je dirais plutôt 1929
2 sur 2 félicitations
c'est la cocotte-minute alors est-ce que
c'est donc
1863 ou 1953 voilà
et donc c'est parfait la pasteurisation
on est donc en 1863 donc vous avez gagné
un petit
becs régale-toi sans prise de bec
on va en reparler dans un instant parce
qu'on est dans la cadeau et on va vous
en faire on va vous en faire goûter mais
avant cela vous savez certainement qu'en
France le repas
occupe une assez large place en
politique vous n'allez pas me contredire
et c'est souvent à table que ce nous les
deals politiques c'est la brève de
comptoir
alors on vous a demandé Agnès faire
malmodo de réfléchir à une anecdote
autour d'un repas en politique est-ce
que vous avez une histoire à nous
raconter alors comme vous l'avez
justement dit j'ai commencé la politique
très tôt il y a très longtemps puisque
je suis né une certaine année de manière
révolutionnaire
enfin révolutionnaire assez récente
quand même énormément
la plus récente des révolutions on va
dire ça
donc j'ai eu l'occasion il a le la
chance de partager pas mal de repas avec
des personnalités politiques donc j'en
ai choisi une particulièrement elle date
d'avril 2002 Jacques Chirac vient Wavre
pour faire campagne il se trouve que
j'étais jeune maman depuis deux mois et
donc j'accueille Jacques Chirac à
l'aéroport donc à l'époque vous êtes ma
mère adjointe à l'époque je suis pas
encore les adjointe encore pas encore au
conseil municipal et je suis député je
suis député suppléant déjà et je suis
député suppléant et
et donc Jacques Chirac arrive à
l'aéroport donc on fait la visite et il
se trouve que ma maman était là et avec
mon fils et Jacques Chirac dit bonjour à
tout le monde et je lui dis bah écoutez
je vous présente mon fils et hop avec sa
grosse main là hop il attrape mon petit
Clément
et ça fait une photo une photo très très
sympa et donc Clément a aujourd'hui 21
ans je pense que le jour où il se
mariera cette photo là elle va ressort
je suis pas sûr que tout le monde est
l'occasion d'avoir une photo dans les
mains d'un président de la République et
en tout cas Jacques Chirac voilà j'ai
très populaire très populaire et qui
venait de faire un grand bain de foule
et c'était plutôt un moment un moment
très sympa voilà il était attendri par
cette par cet enfant vous avez senti que
Jacques Chirac était quand même un homme
extraordinaire et plein d'empathie et
donc de voir un bébé donne-le-moi ton
petit là tu vas voir il avait vraiment
une grande main
c'était comme ça c'était impressionnant
il a été très sympa donc c'est plutôt un
moment un moment sympa mais j'ai le
bonheur d'en avoir connu d'autre voilà
c'est plutôt sympa et Jacques Chirac
vous l'avez connu un petit peu plus vous
avez pu échanger un peu avec lui après
oui oui j'ai eu l'occasion aussi de
faire j'aurais pu choisir des
universités d'été jeune RPR à Strasbourg
donc ça remonte encore là pour le coup
un peu plus dans le temps où Jacques
Chirac était là avec Michel à Lyon Marie
et en dîner avec des jeunes des jeunes
RP bien bien agitées où c'était un repas
très sympa et là pour le coup Jacques
Chirac était très à l'aise sur les
assiettes volantes en papier enfin voilà
c'était très bon moment c'était des
moments festifs aussi pas que mais
celui-là était festif il y a aussi des
moments de travail de travail politique
alors on va maintenant parler des
bonbons puisque c'est un aliment que
vous aimez particulièrement c'est un
aliment qui est aussi régressif par
excellence la tendance est au vegan sans
gélatine de porc les vrais amateurs s'y
retrouvent-ils c'est le dessous des
plats
oui figurez-vous Brigitte que depuis le
confinement on n'a jamais mangé autant
de bonbons en France un petit et grand
confondu et qui ne résiste pas à la
tentation d'une fraise tagada d'une
bouteille de coca gélatineuse Hélène
Bonduelle Aurélia Rusek et André la font
suivi une fan de confiseries capable de
retrouver le goût de notre enfance et
une chimiste qui fabrique des bons becs
naturels moins sucrés reportage à
déguster comme un bonbon
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de produits qu'on trouve
pas en grande surface il y a beaucoup
d'anciens bonbons qu'on ne trouve plus
en grande surface si Elisa est un
tarissable sur ses bonbons c'est qu'elle
est tombée dedans petite et depuis ça ne
l'a plus quitté le goût l'odeur c'est le
sucre qui fait un peu des bulles en
bouche
je sais pas c'est trop bon
au point de créer sa boutique en ligne
plus de 250 références venues du monde
entier et certaines plutôt improbables
on peut manger un toilette
et on a une belle poudre acidulée parce
que les toilettes sont bouchées et du
coup le but c'est d'aller déboucher les
toilettes en mangeant toute la petite
poudre dedans avec la brosse
et c'est bon
bonjour à tous Comment ça va et pour
traquer les bonbons de son enfance Elisa
n'hésite pas à faire appel aux réseaux
sociaux est-ce qu'il y a des produits
des bonbons que vous adoriez quand vous
étiez petit et que je n'ai pas encore
sur le site là la dernière trouvaille
que j'ai réussi à faire c'est les
sucettes drinfees au cola j'ai mis
quelques temps avant de mettre la main
dessus donc c'est les sucettes les
sucettes en forme de bouteille de cola
qui date des années 80 si je dis pas de
bêtises mais les clients d'Elisa
cherchent de nouveaux bonbons plus
naturels vegan et surtout moins sucré
alors c'est le pari de cette start-up je
vous ai apporté des bonbons nickel on
sent bien bien les arômes on va faire
des bonbons à base de fruits qui est le
premier ingrédient beaucoup moins sucré
sans aucun additif c'est-à-dire sans
arôme sans colorant sans conservateur et
également végétaux donc ça peut convenir
à tous les régimes alimentaires ici pas
de gélatine de porc mais de l'agar-agar
et de la pectine et pour l'enrobage de
la fécule de maïs c'est assez important
faut bien trier faut que ça soit bien
enrobé sinon ça ça colle
là on a un beau bonbon bien déshydraté
qui a donc voilà une parfaite texture et
donc avec une super mâche en bouche une
confiserie artisanale avec quatre fois
moins de sucre que les industriels et ce
n'est pas un hasard si c'est ingénieur
chimiste de formation s'est lancé sur ce
marché le marché du bonbon en France
c'est un milliard d'euros c'est le
deuxième marché européen après
l'Allemagne qui représente 3 milliards
d'euros donc c'est vraiment colossal et
le seul bonbon gélifié dans ce marché
c'est 30% de part de marché donc c'est
vraiment le produit préféré des Français
en termes de snacking peut-être juste
après le chocolat et la startup va plus
loin après les bonbons aux fruits les
bonbons alcoolisés pour l'apéritif
saveur mojito vin chaud ou encore pina
colada
alors vous la ministre accro aux bonbons
quels sont les bonbons de votre enfance
que vous regrettez
les Mistral Gagnant c'était le moment de
partir à l'école et on partait cinq
minutes avant pour aller acheter le
mistral gagnant les petites coquilles là
qu'on mettait comme ça inventé par
chanter par Renault magnifique il pleut
assez aujourd'hui je vais pas chanter le
petit coquille
dans le plastique
complètement chimiques tout ça à
l'époque des bonbons même si la ministre
que je suis en charge des problèmes de
santé il doit expliquer que tout ça doit
se faire aussi avec modération
que c'est pas forcément toujours bon
pour la santé quoi que ça peut faire du
bien aussi à faire un tout petit peu
plaisir mais là Jean-Pierre parle de
votre enfance mais vous en mangez
toujours si je ne me trompe pas j'en
mange toujours et beaucoup
c'est sans doute pas bien c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien pour les dents c'est pas
bien pour les dents c'est pas bon pour
les dents d'ailleurs j'ai pas des bonnes
dons donc c'est peut-être ça le sujet
c'est pas bon pour les dents
qui est toujours là au cas d'un petit
coup de mou
j'ai fait un voyage aux États-Unis j'ai
les petits polo la menthe quand voilà
mais j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup c'est pas un secret pour
personne j'aime beaucoup les nounours à
la guimauve à la
guimauveur
dans la poche c'est pas pratique ou
alors pour les petits sachets
on partage aussi les fraises tagada ça
nous est arrivé tous les deux on
conseille municipal ou dans d'autres
instances de partager des petits paquets
de petits paquets de banque c'est vert
que vous en avez toujours sur vous ou
vous en avez planqué dans votre bureau
c'est alors dans mon bureau ils sont pas
planqués il y en a qui sont très
visibles il y a pas un rendez-vous il y
a pas des bonbons sur mon bureau parfois
on les écarte parce que c'est pas bien
d'ailleurs je m'abuse des photos dans
certains journaux où il y avait la boîte
de bonbons pour dire les marques ici
Haribo qui traînaient sur le bureau sur
le bureau donc c'est assumé et c'était
le cas pour Édouard Philippe aussi dans
son bureau il avait un Matignon il avait
un restaurant cette passion pour les
bonbons aussi et je le redis il faut
faire attention c'est important mais
chaque Français consomme en moyenne
trois kilos un peu plus de 3 kg par an
de bonbons c'est des gros consommateurs
ils sont un peu derrière les Allemands
mais vous dites passions parce que c'est
un mot joli passion est-ce que chez vous
c'est presque une addiction est-ce que
vous êtes obligé de vous arrêter
d'arrêter votre chauffeur pour aller
prendre des fraises tagada au PMU du
coin
tous les jours
oui ah oui tous les jours d'accord en
fait vous n'avez jamais cessé d'en
manger en fait non ça doit être une
partie de mon enfance doit rester
toujours un peu enfant dans l'âme c'est
bien je trouve vous dites c'est un peu
bon pour la santé parfois c'est à dire
que c'est un élément un peu rassurant
aussi c'est
alimentaire un petit peu un petit peu de
plaisir et c'est aussi oui c'est
d'autres fumes moi je n'ai jamais fumé
je mange des bonbons mais c'est quand
vous avez un petit écoute stress ou un
petit ou envie de vous détendre un petit
peu ou du tirage alors je n'ai jamais
analysé cette partie de moi d'accord
pour l'expliquer
voilà moi je crois qu'il m'arrive quand
même de ne pas en manger quand il y en a
pas il y en a pas
dans les distributeurs on parliez de
fumée vous souvenez aussi des petites
cigarettes en chocolat ah oui
dans des vrais paquets comme ça là vous
avez l'impression que vous pouvez fumer
c'est vrai que voilà alors il y a des
bonbons que j'aime moins que d'autres
j'aime pas trop les bonbons anglais par
exemple par contre j'aime bien les les
gros rouleaux de réglisse je sais pas
les gros rouleaux de réglisse avec le
petit truc au milieu la petite dragée
station-service exactement la réglisse
c'est le bonbon préféré des Français
pour le cœur c'est pas bon donc pour le
coup faut vraiment consommer avec
modération
faut pas manger de réglisse je suis allé
aux États-Unis j'ai été surpris il y a
plein de bonbons dans les supermarchés
très acidulés et très bizarre j'ai
trouvé un goût pastèque c'était pas mal
j'ai trouvé que c'était assez
du lait mais ça fait aussi parfois
découvrir des goûts par contre
j'aime le chocolat blanc le Galak ah
ouais mais alors ça c'est pas vraiment
du chocolat
j'aime les bonbons et chocolat blanc là
alors il y a une nouvelle tendance vous
avez vu dans ce reportage ce sont des
bonbons alcoolisés est-ce que vous
voulez un petit bonbon pina colada ou
mojito plutôt mojito plutôt alors je
vous laisse choisir parce que je sais
pas exactement après
plutôt celui-là et bon là c'est pareil
modération
est-ce qu'on peut goûter Brigitte
non mais pour voir ce que si cette
tendance est une tendance intéressante
le goût un peu du Mojito je sens que tu
es très gélifié
bon vous êtes pas totalement convaincu
il y a un petit goût de quelque chose de
citron moi j'ai mojito on sent un petit
goût de Mojito
mieux ça veut dire qu'il y a pas trop
d'alcool il faut pas trop d'alcool
d'abord alors là on a aussi des
nouvelles tendances donc du 100% végétal
on a pas de gélatine de porc il y a des
bonbons vegan est-ce que vous vous
regardez ça ou pas du tout vous prenez
vraiment ce qui vous plaît la fraise
tagada je suis plutôt dans dans le
classique classique
voilà mais après moi je comprends que
certains et ton vie de voir et
d'ailleurs si ça existe c'est parce que
il y a un besoin je veux dire que parce
que il y a une demande donc moi je ne
suis pas opposé garantie sans
cochonneries
on va goûter je voudrais vous dire
est-ce que là j'ai fraise et mur blanc
ça vous dit en fait
des bonbons parce que en formation on
trouve des bonbons au miel qui sont bons
pour la toux on trouve des des bonbons
qui ont un côté
médicament non
faut faire la différence entre le
médicament et le bonbon
les bonbons miel on sait que le miel à
cette vertu d'adoucir la gorge
en pharmacie on vend des bonbons en
pharmacie
on vend des bonbons au miel parce que
parfois il y a pas besoin de médicaments
et que le bonbon peut suffire juste à
adoucir la gorge quand on a juste une
petite irritation j'étais dans les
Vosges vendredi dernier le pain des
Vosges c'est aussi cette vertu voilà les
pastilles Vichy pour la digestion
ça marche ça ou c'est un peu de menti
Vichy pour la digestion
encore parfois mais là aussi tout est
une question il faut faire attention il
faut pas vendre des bonbons avec sucre
aux personnes qui sont diabétiques enfin
voilà faut aussi te faire attention à ça
et parfois il y a un mélange des gens il
y a des bonbons au miel qui sont vendus
par les pharmacies puis il y a aussi du
streptyle qui est un médicament avec du
miel et là ça se mange pas comme des
bonbons ça n'est pas un bonbon c'est un
médicament il y en a qui se vend pas au
même endroit
comme dirait l'autre alors j'ai trouvé
des bonbons au CBD oui est-ce que ça
fonctionne ou pas est-ce que ça peut
permettre de soulager peut-être des
petites douleurs alors faut faire la
différence entre le cannabis
thérapeutique qui est en expérimentation
qui permet de soulager les douleurs et
du CBD en bonbon j'ai jamais goûté et en
fait je n'en vendrai pas et je
n'inciterai personne à le goûter voilà
parce que vous pensez quoi que c'est
mauvais je pense que la difficulté sur
ce genre de produit et pour info faire
l'expérience auprès de jeunes collégiens
lorsqu'on a lancé l'expérimentation sur
le cannabis thérapeutique eux avaient
retenu le mot cannabis donc je me méfie
toujours de ces produits qui pourraient
inviter ou inciter nos jeunes à faire
des raccourcis un peu un peu rapides
donc là pour le coup on a un vrai enjeu
de prévention sur tous ces produits là
je serai plutôt assez vigilante
à la fois là c'est la profession de
santé la ministre qui parle alors vous
avez goûté c'est bon bon donc 100%
végétal à la fraise c'est ça et alors
non non c'est pas terrible c'est pas
mauvais
mais j'aime bien
les fraises tagada
je ne sais pas s'ils sont agressifs ça
m'ennuie qu'on parle de bonbons
récréatifs
les bonbons cela sont des bonbons c'est
pas ce que je préfère et les bonbons
gélifiés finalement que les Français
préconisent aussi vous les vous les
aimez particulièrement c'est pas les
petites bouteilles de
cocailles de coca je vois que vous leur
dites sur les bonbons les bleus et les
roses alors là c'était Haribo on a
jamais des roses des verres des jaunes
mais celle-ci
je vais vous dire
mais c'est bon bon là c'est c'est très
mauvais pour la santé alors que alors
que ça quand même ça c'est bon pour la
santé on peut c'est quand même pas
mauvais on est près d'une petite fille
effectivement là quand même bien
meilleur pour la santé c'est bien ils
sont bons gustatives c'est bon on sent
que c'est du travail artisanal c'est à
l'opposé de ces bonbons chimiques ces
deux choses pour ce qu'il faut cumuler
les deux en France c'est fabriqué
il y a une belle usine en France
avec un musée du bonbon
[Rires]
préféré non mais quand même
c'est pas très ragoutant de les voir
mélanger leur truc là alors maintenant
qu'on a parlé des bonbons il y a pas mal
de sucre en général ça fait un peu
grossir à quelques semaines des vacances
d'été bah il est temps de penser à son
body summer n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre ok
sur les coupes sont-ils vraiment
efficaces et bon pour la santé
on en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat
alors au pays de la gastronomie les bons
petits plats ne font pas forcément bon
ménage avec les régimes difficile de
garder la ligne certains n'hésitent pas
à user des coupes fin vendus en
pharmacie pour réguler leur fringales et
leur envie de grignoter mais réellement
efficace c'est une enquête de Pierre
Miquel Carniel et des mashallah
lorsqu'on parle de coupe-faim on pense
rarement à des procédés naturels
pas très catholiques faire un régime je
suppose faire un régime et prendre des
médicaments pour couper l'appétit à pour
moi ça évoque la chimie avant tout voilà
c'est toujours
car pour beaucoup ce mot rappelle le
scandale du Médiator ce médicament
prescrit à plus de 5 millions de
personnes entre 1976 et 2009 à causé
près de 2000 décès avant son retrait du
marché plus récemment c'est l'eau en pic
qui a fait polémique ce traitement à
destination des diabétiques a été
détournée au point de provoquer des
ruptures de stock pour les patients qui
en ont besoin utilisez en injection pour
maigrir plusieurs influenceuses en font
la promotion sur Tik Tok
je pouvais plus la mettre depuis que
j'ai eu ma fille aujourd'hui je la mets
avec une ceinture que je ne pouvais non
plus mettre donc voilà je suis trop
contente en pharmacie plutôt que les
solutions chimiques ont conseillent les
conformes naturelles il y a plein de
choses en fin de compte au niveau
aromathérapie au niveau phytothérapie où
on peut effectivement
avoir de très bons résultats donc déjà
ça c'est une aide et après le discours
d'orienter au niveau de la base c'est
pour moi c'est l'alimentation d'ailleurs
Hippocrate le disait notre meilleur
médicament c'est ce qu'on met dans
l'assiette nous avons soumis à l'analyse
d'une diététicienne des dérivés de
plantes d'algues et de racines aux
vertus modératrices d'appétit
alors même s'ils sont dit naturel ils
sont pas non plus sans danger par
rapport au konjac ça va agir comme une
éponge etc bah moi quand je vois neuf
kcal pour 100 g les apports moyens d'un
adulte sont entre 1800 à demi kilocal
donc est-ce que ça règle vraiment les la
problématique en fait de la fin le
tartare d'algues par exemple donc c'est
très riche en iode en excès on va avoir
un apport excédentaire au niveau de
l'yote donc on va avoir des soucis au
niveau de la thyroïde au niveau
cardiovasculaire au niveau rénal pour
elle la solution se trouve ailleurs
tout ce qui va être naturel pourquoi pas
mais c'est pas dans une idée forcément
perte de poids couffin etc il faut aussi
que l'assiette à côté soit équilibrée
notre corps c'est une formidable magie
qui est très complexe qui a besoin comme
une voiture qui a besoin de son
carburant l'excès est mauvais certes le
manque également est très mauvais pour
la santé une alimentation à réguler
plutôt qu'à modérer afin d'éviter de
développer des troubles du comportement
alimentaire en France il concerne près
de 2 millions de personnes
est-ce que vous voyez des vertus assez
coupant Agnès faire malbodo est-ce que
c'est bien pour essayer de maigrir de
moins grignoter alors c'est comme ça a
été développé dans le reportage c'est de
façon cyclique et vous l'avez dit
vous-même en introduction au printemps
on voit bien que ce sujet qui ne
concerne pas que les femmes je pense
qu'il est aussi important de dire que
parfois les hommes aussi ont envie mais
oui de d'être tout beau pour se mettre
en maillot de bain
on voit bien que c'est la saison où
reviennent régulièrement ces questions
là aussi je pense qu'il est important de
dire que d'abord détourner de l'usage
des médicaments pour des coupe-faims je
pense qu'il faut que se souvienne le
sujet sur le sujet du Médiator qui a
quand même été en France juste un
problème de santé publique dramatique et
donc ce que je vois avec le zapping
m'inquiète et je suis plutôt rassuré
alerte
je dis pas à futur scandale je dis je
suis plutôt rassurée qu'on prenne plutôt
en amont cette problématique et
tant pis qui est destiné aux personnes
diabétiques et uniquement aux personnes
diabétiques son autorisation de bus sur
le marché a été faite pour traiter les
personnes diabétiques et non pas pour
maigrir donc ça veut dire que les
médecins ne doivent pas préconise
pas écrire les empiriques voilà que ça
ne doit pas être vendu comme un produit
voilà c'est bien un médicament qui est
destiné à traiter les personnes
diabétiques et ce qui est dommage c'est
qu'on voit qu'il y a des problèmes de
rupture de stock parce que ce produit
peut être détourné de son usage donc là
voilà après il y a le sujet des coups de
fins dit naturel
je pense que le meilleur coupe-feu c'est
de boire un bon verre d'eau ça remplit
bien l'estomac c'est naturel c'est
d'aller manger une pomme par hasard
aussi parfois c'est juste peut-être même
un petit bout de pain ça gonfle bien
dans l'estomac pas de bonbons pas de
bonbons sont pas des coupe-faims
qui sont plutôt naturels après on peut
aussi prendre des plantes et on voit
bien qu'il y a des plantes qu'on sait de
vertus j'allais dire de gonfler dans
l'estomac et de de de de couper cette
envie euh
digérer est-ce qu'on va pas se jeter sur
un gâteau voilà donc le risque c'est
celui-là c'est ce que dit le risque
c'est il faut être très prudent et je le
redis tout est question d'équilibre et
de proportion et le risque de vouloir
absolument maigrir c'est de se détourner
de l'alimentation et on a besoin de
manger on a besoin de manger donc tout
est une question proportion on revient à
ce que nous disions tout à l'heure oui
mais on n'est pas attention égaux devant
l'alimentation
à côté faire un peu d'activité physique
c'est aussi important ça fait partie de
la problématique et du sujet pour
certaines personnes voilà c'est manger
bouger c'est aussi ça
voilà et c'est couffins qui ne sont pas
naturels on est un peu au-delà du
territoire de l'alimentation ils sont
prescrits par des médecins où ils
peuvent être ils sont en vente libre ils
sont en vente libre je sors de
l'Olympique et du médiateur qui sont des
médicaments destinés à traiter leur
médiateur n'existe plus
ou alors donc il est prescrit par les
médecins lui
[Musique]
comprimés dans la journée c'est c'est
bien respecter les posologies et pendant
une période donnée mais tout en
continuant à manger de façon
proportionnelle à côté parce que
l'alimentation nous apporte toujours
quelque chose dont nous avons besoin et
l'énergie notamment tout ça l'énergie et
après quand on veut maigrir et bah faut
réduire les quantités en fait c'est
aussi faire du sport réduire les
quantités manger équilibrer manger
équilibré voilà c'est tout ça
donc vous dites pour prendre
l'expression body je sais pas quoi là
donc pour le body summer pas de
coupe-faim mais plutôt une pomme
voilà
et proportionné il faut pas oublier de
manger c'est important de manger et
pourtant à la fin du reportage on entend
deux millions de personnes ont des
troubles du comportement alimentaire
vous vous envoyez de plus en plus vous
diriez dans dans votre pharmacie des
personnes qui aussi chez les jeunes
filles qui ne mangent pas les jeunes
filles anorexiques ça va aussi ça les
troubles de comportement alimentaire
c'est aussi dans l'autre sens des jeunes
filles qui ne qui ne mangent plus du
tout et là c'est c'est plutôt qu'avec
que des problèmes du trouble de
comportement alimentaire c'est mais
c'est aussi ça donc faut être très
prudent sur les messages qu'on envoie
par rapport à l'alimentation
manger il le faut c'est sain nous avons
besoin de manger notre corps a besoin
d'eau et a besoin d'énergie et c'est
besoin de de protéines de vitamines et
c'est l'alimentation équilibrée et
proportionnée qui nous l'apportent
est-ce que vous dites attention aux
réseaux sociaux on voit parfois des
jeunes filles qui doivent rentrer dans
une feuille A4 pour pouvoir
effectivement être à la mode et comme
les autres et qui entraîne peut-être des
troubles du comportement alimentaire
vous avez pu conseiller attention aux
réseaux sociaux pour beaucoup de sujets
et celui-là pour les jeunes filles en
particulier l'important c'est d'être
bien dans sa tête et dans sa peau
et on peut être bien dans sa tête et
dans sa peau avec un excès de poids
l'important c'est d'être bien dans sa
tête et dans sa peau et de pas
ressembler à ce qu'on ne peut pas être
et de pas ressembler quand on est
adolescent mais c'est pas toujours nous
avons aussi parfois en tant que parents
un devoir d'explication un devoir de
vigilance j'allais dire la société de
voir de vigilance et d'explication par
rapport à ça l'important c'est d'être ce
qu'on peut être c'est d'être bien dans
sa tête et dans sa peau
alors on va à présent passer au dessert
et c'est le péché mignon
alors le temps du sucré avec un riz au
lait le riz au lait en fait originaire
de rasie on a trace de riz cuit au lait
sucré en Asie centrale comme nourriture
des chevaux chez les Mongols aux
alentours de l'an 1000 donc il est vieux
notre ryolet mais le riz au lait tel
qu'on le déguste aujourd'hui fait son
apparition seulement au 19e siècle il
était un potage un peu lourd et puis il
devient d'un seul coup un vrai dessert
sucré et une recette et même mentionnée
dès 1868 la cuisine classique d'Urbain
du bois entoure un riz au lait à la
vanille de pommes meringuée nappée de
sauce abricot pas mal le nôtre est plus
simple et là je me dis là je me dis
après les bonbons le riz au lait tout ça
est régressif il faut peut-être aller
voir un psychanalyse
ça va pas du tout
d'abord le riz au lait réapparaît dans
beaucoup de cartes
donc non non mais dites
sa grand-mère votre arrière-grand-mère
qui est donc c'est très bon mais mais
c'est pas régressif du tout et vous avez
chez vous c'est pas le riz au lait c'est
la torgule la teurgoule
c'est aussi très bon
c'est pas pareil je préfère j'aime bien
le riz au lait vous en faites chez
jamais réussi à le faire bien je n'y
arrive pas en fait j'ai un gros problème
avec la cuisson du riz voilà c'est même
le riz classique j'arrive pas à le cuire
donc parce qu'en fait je ne suis pas le
temps je j'oublie dites-nous comment
vous le trouvez ça m'intéresse
comme je l'aime
formidable
ils ont trouvé la recette que j'aime
bien alors j'aime un autre dessert c'est
le flan fermier mais pas le flan
pâtissier oui le flan fermier
quoi
dans un endroit dans une boulangerie
c'est tout
à le reproduire non une personne qui
s'en approche mais mais
je trouve très vanillé je l'aime
beaucoup parce qu'il est très fort je le
trouve un tout petit peu al dente j'aime
bien qu'on le riz est un peu plus mou
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
difficile à faire cuire il y en a qui
commence à le faire cuire dans de l'eau
puis ensuite ils le mettent dans du lait
vous pouvez aussi le mettre dans du lait
moi je mets un petit peu de sel un petit
peu de beurre et puis après du lait
entier et puis il faut le couvrir le
couvrir le faire cuire très longtemps
mais toujours venir le nourrir en lait
parce que ensuite il va boire le lait et
peut être assez sec une fois qu'il est
refroidit donc c'est un effort il faut
le faire cuire très longtemps pour qu'il
soit un peu à la fin un peu mou je
trouve donc Les bonbons c'est régressif
le riz au lait serrésressif le Condrieu
c'est quoi un an le candidate
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
chez Françoise qui nous a régalé pendant
tout ce dont avec ses crevettes et
souris au lait délicieux merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis on se retrouve
bien sûr la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP